the 14th of june marks 15 years of an
israeli land air in sea blockade of the
gaza strip that's one of the most
densely populated areas in the world
two million palestinians live in what
has been described as the world's
largest open-air prison
since hamas took over the gaza strip in
2007 after legislative elections israel
has imposed a full siege on the enclave
it strictly controls everyone and
everything going in or out
it's further damaged gaza's bleak
economy and the dire living conditions
of its 2 million people
and that's been worsened by both israel
and egypt keeping their borders closed
israel allows passage through the aries
crossing only in what it considers
exceptional humanitarian cases
in human rights watch latest report on
israel's siege it states the closure has
devastated the economy in gaza
contributed to fragmentation of the
palestinian people and forms part of
israeli authorities crimes against
humanity of appetite and persecution
against millions of palestinians
israeli authorities should lift the
closure of gaza end the generalized
travel ban and permit freedom of
movement subject to at most individual
screenings for security reasons
more than 60 percent are refugees
depending on the united nations refugees
agency for food education and medical
aid there's no tomorrow actually here in
in the gaza strip
i will give you one figure about the
number of people who used to receive
food from on raw food coupons from umrah
in 2000 the number was 70 000 people now
we are talking about 1 million 100 000
people this is how the numbers are you
know
rising
hussein once owned a factory producing
medical and industrial equipment but
israeli officials stop materials
entering gaza they say can be used for
dual use meaning civilian and military
he says that's left him and more than 30
other workers without jobs
[Music]
many essential materials from our
factory were banned from entering gaza
this caused our factory to stop working
it's a piece of junk now and we were
forced to send all workers home
since israel imposed its blockade it's
also launched for military assaults on
gaza
with the siege preventing construction
materials such as steel and cement from
reaching gaza reconstruction has been
near impossible
the u.n warned in 2015 that living
conditions in gaza were deteriorating so
rapidly it could become uninhabitable by
2020
now in 2022 palestinians in gaza are
still living under israel's blockade
denied their basic right to freedom and
with little or no hope of a better
future
you must
al jazeera gaza